was an
Al okay thanks ali um so I mean I I
prepared the talk and I realized that
the ttle is very cryptic so really what
I'm going to talk about is I'm going to
talk about uh my perspective an
algebraic perspective linear algebra
perspective uh on a new algorithm for
solving linear linear equations the new
algorithm is not by me it's my
perspective on somebody else's algorithm
uh and the algorithm is a randomized
graph algorithm for solving uh linear
equations was really delighted to be
invited to this workshop and I thought
so thanks Michael and I thought uh that
you know beyond the technical talk I
maybe should uh give something back
something slightly more General and I've
decided to uh offer an Insight that
obviously pertains to this particular
talk um puts the talk in some sort of
context but hopefully slightly more
General and the uh the core of this uh
Insight is that PR practitioners can
take theoretical results theoretical
ideas theoretical algorithms and turn
them into really uh fantastic software
so this is just the core the full
Insight this is true but only in theory
um and in practice uh this is often uh
sometimes it's possible but often this
is very hard uh or impossible I guess
for theoreticians this is this is this
is just fine it's not uh disconcerning
at all because in theory all is well but
for practitioners like me uh there is an
issue here now I'm not complaining uh at
all um I like this situation because
really what it means is it means that I
can uh uh read theoretical papers learn
that the theory discover really exciting
results results that really excite me um
and sometimes the theoretician thinks
that there is still a long way to go
sometimes the theoretician may think
that that's the end of the story and
everything is done but for me I know
that there is still a way to go in terms
of uh doing really really interesting
research to bridge the gap between the
theoretical result and what's going on
in practice and uh the talk I'm going to
u to give today is really a talk that uh
where I'm going to walk through with you
part of the way not all the way to
Fantastic software but part of the way
uh that himim and I uh uh with some help
from Heim Kaplan did to bridge this gap
between uh what was really a very
exciting theoretical result and the
Fantastic software that we hope will be
able to uh to deliver one day uh so the
setup is really very very simple we want
to solve linear systems of equations
ideally we would want to solve linear
systems of equation ax equals B without
any side constraints but this was this
is a a workshop on Big Data uh and ser
gay said correctly uh on Monday that we
really want to try to focus on on
problems that we can solve in linear
time or n Logan or close to linear time
and unfortunately even though these uh
linear systems are really the simplest
type of high dimensional problems that
you can imagine we don't know how to
solve all of them uh in anything close
to linear time so what do you do is you
pile up more side constraints so let's
assume that the Matrix is also symmetric
that it's sparse that it's semi-definite
or positive definite uh which still uh
uh which is a class that still contains
a lot of very important practical
problems and it turns out that uh even
with all of those sign side constraints
we don't know how to solve them in
anything close to uh linear time so we
had one more constraint which really uh
should nail the coffin and that's that
it's diagonally dominant so diagonally
dominant is really a very strong side
constraint because what it means it
means that the Matrix is fundamentally
isomorphic to a weighted graph uh and
that gives enough structure to come up
with graph algorithms that really are
very very powerful and uh one one sub
class of diag dominant matrices which
I'm going to focus on because it's
easier to explain what's going on uh are
llans of graphs so here we have two
graphs here is a two-dimensional mesh
it's an unweighted mesh I numbered the
vertices and if there is an edge between
vertex I and vertx J one and two then
the Matrix has a a nonzero value in
position one two or six seven there will
be a POS in a a67 will be non zero this
graph is unweighted so the absolute
value of the off diagonals is all ones
the diagonal has the degree the weighted
degree this is an unweighted version
there are weighted versions uh and you
can generate a llas any graph this is a
two- dimensional m threedimensional m
and uh you can create Aion for
unstructured mes expanders any any any
kind of graph so we want to solve linear
systems that are isomorphic uh to
weighted
graphs uh so how do you solve linear
systems so we'll we'll start with really
ancient uh history so the the the
history is really ancient so it started
something like two these algorithms were
invented the first algorithms and
algorithms that we still use every day
were invented invented something like
200 years ago uh by gaus and choleski uh
one idea is to factor the coefficient
Matrix into triangular factors if the
Matrix is positive definite or
semi-definite you can Factor it into a
triangular factor and its transpose uh
unfortunately the gaus didn't know about
the big data so he came up with an N
cubed algorithm uh so this is really
okay so no big no no uh in the uh like
John said yesterday in the 50s 60s 7s
people realized that if the Matrix is
sparse you can take advantage of that uh
there are very clever algorithms that
that factor uh sparse matrices and if
you specialize to let's say two
dimensional measures like the one I
showed before then it's much much better
the complexity arithmetic complexity is
much much better than n cubed it's n to
the one and a half for 3D measures it's
n uh it's quadratic n squar so this is
much better than gaus and elimination on
a full Matrix but still uh too expensive
for Big Data uh another point which will
which John said yesterday and is
important in the rest of the talk is
that uh these exponents the complexity
really depends on the size of balanced
vertex separators that you can find in
the graph of the Matrix if the if you
have the Matrix has small separators
then you can solve uh the linear system
very efficiently if it doesn't have
small separators uh you can solve this
efficiently so in the roughly end of the
70s early 80s people uh got to this
point uh it's great but it's not uh what
you really hope for so is there anything
else and the answer the answer is yes
there is another completely different
class of algorithms that actually preced
this a little bit there from the 50s and
60s uh which are examplified by
conjugate gradient there are a lot of
them but the most famous is conjugate
gradient these are iterative algorithms
in which you have an approximate
solution Vector XT and you repeatedly
iteratively update it and you know in
such a way that it converges to the
solution X the cost of each iteration is
the number of nonzeros in The Matrix a
or if it's isomorphic to a graph the
number of edges which will denote by m
so it's easy to understand the cost of
each iteration it's harder to understand
how many iterations you need in order uh
for the solution to converge to
something close to the exact solution
and it turns out that this depends on
the distribution of igen values of this
Matrix a if the igen values are
clustered then convergence will be rapid
if it's not clustered convergence will
be uh slow and this really is not not a
rephrasing of of gauss's ideas in any
form or shape this is really completely
different and the way I'm I'm going to
uh convince you try to convince you that
this is really completely different is
by uh saying
or by mentioning that these algorithms
are faster on 3D meshes than on 2D
meshes so what was hard for gaussin
elimination is easy for this and this is
exactly for the same reason so if the
Matrix has a large separ doesn't have
small separators then conjugate gradient
converges quickly if it has small
separators then it's great for sparse
gar elimination but not good for
conjugate gradient so this is uh this is
really completely different but it
turned out to be really way way too slow
on many meses many many uh practical
problems uh and the next idea was to say
okay so we have these two completely
different classes of algorithms can we
mesh them together in some way the the
overall algorithm will take will enjoy
the benefits of both of them uh and this
turned out to be uh possible using a
technique from the 60s and' 70s U called
preconditioning so the idea is you say
Okay so the coefficient Matrix is a and
if it was very very sparse or had small
separators I would Factor it and and and
solve the linear system but it's too
expensive to factor can I find an
approximation P preconditioner so can I
find an approximation of a called P I'll
denoted by P so that I can afford to
factor P into triangular factors and
then I'll use this factorization to
transform the linear system to an
equivalent linear system but which has a
different coefficient Matrix this L
inverse a l to the minus transpose which
really fundamentally is a symmetric
version of P inverse a so if p is
similar to a then you expect P inverse
to be similar to a inverse and P inverse
a to be close to the identity and it
turns out that if it's close to the
identity it doesn't need to be close to
the identity in Matrix space it needs to
be close to the identity in the sense
that its igen values are cluster the
identity has just one IG value that's
repeating many times one uh so if the
igen values of this coefficient Matrix
are clustered this this will converge
very quickly and hopefully you can find
a p uh so that factoring it will be much
faster than factoring a uh when people
discovered this uh this scheme uh they
started looking for ways to construct p
and for many years the only ways to
construct P were either Uris sixs in
which it was very difficult to say
anything concrete about the convergence
rates or uh it was very problem specific
uh until in
1991 the theory Community came up with a
really cool algorithm to construct these
matrices P these preconditioners in a
way that allows uh for a very satisfying
analysis of the convergence rate and the
total uh total uh solution cost let me
describe the basic algorithm is very
simple so we have a mesh here and we
notice that the mesh is isomorphic to a
graph so it's not just that the Matrix
has a graph of its nonzero it's an
isomorphism so anything you do on the
mesh really corresponds to something
algebraic that you do on the Matrix and
what's more natural if you looking for
small separators to say okay this
doesn't the smallest separator here will
be 11 uh 11 vertices let's try to drop
some of the edges to make the separator
smaller so you can start with this
coefficient Matrix and sparsify it so
here we've spar if I it all the way to
uh to a tree if I delete this vertex for
example I chop it into two roughly equal
uh Parts by just removing one vertex so
factoring this thing is going to be very
easy now what about the uh these igen
values of P inverse times a well it
doesn't look that tree doesn't look that
much uh like a so probably the I values
are not going to be very cluster then
you can prove that they're not going to
be very clustered but you you don't have
to be that greedy so you can look for
something like this where it's still
meshy it still looks like a mesh it's
still pretty similar but still uh the
separator is now half the size uh and
here the separator is even smaller uh
and it turns out that there is a way to
analyze rigorously these preconditioners
and they're based on a very important
idea which is going to play out
throughout the talk so you have to pay
attention to this and the idea is that
you change the representation you don't
do any work it's not an algorithm you
just change a representation of the
problem from what is effectively the
jjcy Matrix Matrix of the graph to the
incidence Matrix of the graph so U is an
incidence factor it's a uh matrix it's a
um short and fed Matrix the rows
correspond to vertices in the graph and
the columns correspond to edges in the
graph and the column that corresponds to
Edge e which is i j has just two
nonzeros uh the square root or the
square root of the absolute value of AI
J and minus the square root of the
absolute value of AI and it turns out
that if you take the outer product of of
this column and its transpose which what
happen which is what happens here you
reconstruct the original Matrix so we
moved from one represent algebraic
representation of the graph to another
representation of the graph and this uh
this was key to a discovery in 2003 so
the combinator conditions started in
1991 using a a fairly complicated type
of analysis but in 2001 Bowman and
Hendrickson uh used these incidence
factors to come up with a very clean
neat and useful way to characterize the
convergence rate of these algorithms and
what they said is they said okay we have
this incidence Factor U and we're using
a subgraph as a preconditioner so let's
uh order The Columns of U so that the
subgraphs the basic uh variables the B
the basic uh edges show up first and
then there are the edges that we've
dropped the non-basic edges so p is
really the outer product of the
incidence Factor U * U trans transpose
and uh
if it's a spinning subgraph then there
is a matrix W that transforms this
incidence factor into the original
incidence factor and it's very easy to
see that you can construct these W's
from path embedding so convincing
yourself that such a w exists is really
uh pretty easy and once you do this you
can construct W anywh you want once you
do this you can show that the bound on
the the the um igen values of this uh
preconditioned Matrix lie between one
and the two Norm of w so it gives you a
bound on the clustering of the igen
values of the precondition system uh now
the two Norm is kind of hard to estimate
but you can bound the two Norm by other
norms and these other Norms like the
infinity Norm the one Norm the fenus
norm are related to combinatorial
properties of the embedding from which
you construct a w like congestion
dilation stretch other uh graph
embedding properties so that gives you a
tool to really look at the two graphs do
graph reasoning and come up with an
algebraic bound on the spectrum of the
preconditioned system and with this uh
technique and also earlier more
complicated techniques people came up
with a whole bunch of algorithms to
sparsify graphs in a way that's useful
in this context uh maximum spinning
trees all kind of uh constructions like
the one I showed before are due to Anil
Joshi the one I want to point out is
these low stretch trees so low low
stretch trees Bowman and Hendrickson
realized at the same time that they
discover these d W's uh they discovered
that low stretch trees uh have uh good
bounds and the forbus norm which
translates into a good bound on the on
the on the torm which uh translates into
R rapid convergence okay so that uh
that's n none of this is really new but
in a couple of months ago himim uh said
okay have you seen this uh very exciting
result from stock
2013 by John Kellner Ora seed for and
Jew uh k and a couple of his studes uh
what was so I said no I looked at the
paper uh what's the paper the paper is
really about the new algorithm and now
you can understand why we got so excited
I mean this is a a problem that people
have been solving inventing algorithms
for for since ga's time and it's not
clear that there's anything new to
discover here and they claim that they
have a new algorithm very exciting for
us uh the algorithm is iterative so I
said okay it must be some rephrasing of
these all algorithms from 1991 2004 and
so on but no it's a different algorithm
it doesn't use conjugate gradient it
doesn't use anything like conjugate
gradient it's iterative but not
conjugate
gradient uh the analysis was completely
new doesn't didn't build on any of the
earlier analysis it it was based on some
kind of uh electrical reasoning which to
me as a person vers in linear algebra
seemed kind of weird I've seen it before
used as a as a motivation but not really
as an analytical
Tool
uh so is it completely new it says it's
completely new but it uses these low
stretch trees where did they come up
from I mean is it somehow related to the
old results can I use my insights about
these old results 10 or 20 years of
research is there anything useful in
these old results but if the result is
cast in a completely new uh type of
analysis is it was very hard for us to
understand whether it's related and how
it's related to all the results and
because of this uh hint the low Street
pH I said okay it must be closely
related to things that people did before
but it just expressed in a different way
and himim and I uh searched and found a
way to express this in a way that's more
understandable to us hopefully more
useful in in implementations and reveals
the structure the relationship between
this result and earlier results uh so
that's what I'm going to show so what's
the what's the algorthm the Alm is
really weird so you start uh with this
uh Matrix which I said you can express
as a uh either a the adjacent or the
outer product of the incidence factors
it's just a different representation no
computation here and you start so but
this Matrix is n byn and this is n by m
uh so it's larger so you take this uh
fat larger mat Matrix and you say it's
not large enough I'm going to make it
even larger so you expand it into a
square square Matrix that's M by n
number of edges by the number of edges
you make the linear system much bigger
and you expand it so here's the U the U
block you you add an N block to make it
square and full Rank and you do this in
a very specific way which sounds very
hard you add a basis for the null space
of of U so you take the rows of you take
U and you find the basis uh for the Nile
space so U * n transpose should be zero
normally it's hard to find Nile space
bases you turn this into a bigger Matrix
and then you take that bigger Matrix is
the coefficient Matrix of a new linear
system a f equals 0 B and I'll refer to
this z b as a right hand side called G
uh and you solve this linear system
which is bigger than the original once
you solve uh F satisfies two block
equations UF equals B and NF equals z UF
equals b means that f is orthogonal to
the null space of uh to IS F is
orthogonal to the to the null space n
which is the null space of U which means
that it is in the RO space of U or the
column space of U transpose which means
that there is an X such that U transpose
x equals F turns out that because of the
incident structure of U it's easy to
find that X if you have F finding X is
easy so first you you construct n then
you solve this linear system you find F
then you find X that's easy and now
because you have the equation UF equals
B that's
UF UF is U * U X which is axal B and
you've solved the problem obviously this
complicated scheme only makes sense if
solving KF equals g is guaranteed to be
easy and that's the way they've
constructed this algorithm in a very
clever way that guarantees that maybe
solving ax equals B is easy or hard it
doesn't matter solving KX equals kfal g
is always easy okay so uh how do they
solve KF equals g they went back uh to
an algorithm for 1937 which is really a
a version of a general scheme from the
19 century called constraint relaxation
iterations which really is the easiest
thing you can think of you take the you
take an approximate solution F which
still doesn't satisfy KF equals g you
say it doesn't satisfy the equation
let's find one equation that it doesn't
satisfy so you say okay let's look at
the I equation does it satisfy the ey
equation no let's fix the approximate
Sol solution F so that it satisfies this
equation maybe this ruins satisfaction
of other equations but you don't care
about this you just do this and repeat
there are several uh ways to do the
update to update the approximate
solution F or ft uh to satisfy equation
I so there's Jacobi relaxation that's
the easiest one you modify the diagonal
element
fi uh they uh used an algorithm called
kage which corrects uh the solution uh
by adding a scaled copy of the row that
is not satisfied so you look at a row
times your approximate solution and if
it's not satisfied you take that sparse
row and you add a um a scalar multiple
of it to your approximate solution to
make it uh to to satisfy the equation
this has a geometric this is a
projection it has a geometric reasoning
on why it makes sense to do this which
is not really important in this talk
you're basically moving f as little as
possible in uh in cian space to satisfy
that equation so they're using uh this
equ so so they're using this method by
Kash uh and they use this method by kman
Kash in a very specific way that's
important uh for ensuring that this that
the algorithm runs fast on KF equals z
what they do is they start from an f0o
which they find using a a another
algorithm which is really easy not very
complicated so they start from an
initial guess that satisfies UF equals B
so it satisfies the top the top
equations but not the bottom equations
NF equals something else I denoted it by
Z which is in general not not zero and
it's easy to see that when you run kage
on this Matrix because this is a a basis
for denal space it uh ft always
satisfies this equation U * ft always
equals b z the bottom part is not zero
but it converges to zero and the reason
it happens is very easy if you pick an
equation that's in the U Block it's
already satisfied this is the invariant
and if you pick an equation n * one of
the rows of n * F uh should be equal to
zero it's not zero you you fix X you fix
F but you what you do to F is you add a
vector that's in the null space of U so
it doesn't make it doesn't uh violate
the equation UF equals B so you always
remaining in that
invariant uh
Subspace Okay so that's that's the
that's the algorithm there is nothing
more to the algorithm but there are
three hard questions one is how to
construct and cheaply in general it's
hard it's expensive to construct n space
bases uh how how many iterations will
this take and how to run them very
efficiently so the uh how do they
construct the n space basis they split
and now this is our explanation of what
they do they would explain this in a
completely different way but what
they're really doing is they're doing
this splitting of you into the basic and
non-basic uh variables where U
represents a spinning tree and therefore
it has this Matrix W that you can
construct combinatorially that will
transform UB into U and obviously
because u u shows up here and also shows
up here this W has a lot of structure uh
its leftmost block is the identity so
you have an identity times the and then
the interesting part of n which I of w
which I denoted by w n
once you come up with this expression
it's very easy to show these three lines
to show that not this Matrix not W but a
some derivation of it minus w n
transpose I is a outpace basis and you
prove this just by multiplying by U and
you get a zero which means that it's a
um that it's uh an outpace basis now how
do you construct W uh I basically said
this before you construct W using a path
embedding so because every column in UE
whether it's a basic or non-basic has
two non zeros uh and all the columns in
youu have two non zeros basically you
line up columns so that the non zeros
cancel out until you get uh the two non
zeros at the end uh it's trivial to
derive those coefficients basically a
column of u specifies a path in the tree
that connects the two end points of the
edge that you dropped that you're trying
to express uh algebraically now what
would make a good n something that makes
kaj Mage converge quickly and the
conversion of kaj Mage is determined by
or bounded by the some condition number
of the coefficient Matrix K by the fenus
norm of the Matrix times the two Norm of
the inverse of the Matrix uh for uh in
this application because the reason they
started from this special uuo is to make
not all of K matter but only the N part
because really your iteration you're
running kage on a rectangular Matrix
this n Matrix the U part really doesn't
pay any any role in the iteration so
what you want is you want an N with a
small sum of squares that's the forus
norm and that cannot make vectors small
that's the two Norm of the pseudo
inverse and it turns out that this
Matrix is good uh the the pseudo inverse
is is never uh never uh never too large
uh because of the I block here and the
fenus norm is really the fenus Norm of w
which is the stretch of the tree so that
shows you why they chose a low stretch
tree and it shows that the the choice of
the low stretch tree and the structure
of the algorithm is really
completely uh built on those on that
Matrix W which was The Matrix that was
used to analyze uh the combinatorial
graph precondition since uh 1991 or
since 2003 when it was uh discovered so
that's why they use the low stretch tree
because it it makes make sure that the
npace basis is a npace basis that makes
Kash converge uh
quickly uh now
um the other really very important
advance that they made was a way to run
kashmar iteration iterations in a way
that makes every iteration very very
cheap uh and to do that they looked at
the expression so they say Okay so we're
going to update F how is f updated f is
updated by a scalar multiple Alpha of
the row that we are trying to fix K the
we're trying to fix row I how do you
choose Alpha you choose Alpha uh using
this uh formula which ensures that you
satisfy uh equation I and most of the
terms here in terms of the uh progress
of the itations are constant you can
pre-compute them ahead of time GI uh
this uh this dot product uh this sum of
squares they're all fixed the only thing
that's interesting in this part this is
an a DOT product between constant
that lie on the path in the graph they
depend both on the path and on the edges
that you Traverse times the current
solution and what they tried to do was
to come up with an abstract data
structure that supports three abstract
operations one operation computes those
dot those dot products so basically
wanted to create a data structure data
structure that's an oracle that you can
say here is a path in the tree what's
the dot product of my current vector
along that path that's one operation the
other operation is say okay uh it should
be the do product should be some one
thing but it's something else let's
modify the flow the this F along the
path so that it would satisfy the
equation by adding Alpha time Ki and at
the end this is a the f is represented
implicitly in this data structure at the
end of the algorithm you really need f
as a set of numbers as a vector of n
numbers so you need to be able to uh to
to Output them but you need to do this
only when you when you decide to stop
the iteration so this you can do this
when you tear down the data structure
you don't need to do this efficiently
all the time now so it looks almost
doable but it was not doable because
here this K in this inner product K the
indexes of K are I and J so it means
that the inner product is between the
current uh solution vector and constants
that lie on the path in the tree but the
constant depends both on the edge that
you're traversing in the path and on the
path on the end points of the path and
there's no nobody knows how to do this
uh abstract data structure efficiently
but they discovered that uh you can do
an algebraic transformation I won't show
it here it's uh too detailed it's not
very complicated but too detailed uh in
a way that removes the I index from the
coefficient here so you can move to
basically a different space in which
these dot products involve constants
that belong to the edges so you have a
tree every edge of the in the tree has a
constant and the variable and what
you're doing is you're taking uh paths
in the tree and you're Computing the dot
product of the constant times the
variable along the path five
minutes uh summing this up uh getting
getting a constant that you turn into
Alpha and then you update the path uh
using a structured way that a data
structure can can do efficiently uh and
they their data structure can do this in
O of Lan it's a really interesting data
structure it's not that
complicated uh they they're very adamant
in the paper saying that it's not very
complicated uh there is a reason that
they're so insistent and the reason it's
that it's a special case of a very
general data structure called Dynamic
trees that was invented by Slater and
Taron uh and when I when I so I said
okay I looked at this I it was hard for
me to understand they explain how to do
this it was hard for me to explain uh
and we have in my department uh an
expert in data structure uh H Kaplan who
was a student of Taran so I said okay
I'll take this to uh to himim and ask
him how how it's done what's the data
structure he said oh Dynamic data
Dynamic trees nobody uses Dynamic trees
they're way too
complicated I said oh boy but then we
read the paper carefully together uh and
we realized that John Ker's uh claim is
absolutely correct that here the tree
doesn't change so this application of
the dynamic data structure is really uh
simple it's implementable it's it's it's
not complicated and we figured this out
completely so
so uh so it's based on something very
complicated but it's a simple
instantiation okay we've got to my last
slide which is two slides wrapped in one
because the is saying that I ran out of
time uh so the summary is really
interesting it's an it's it is a very
exciting new algorithm it's not directly
related to combinatorial preconditioners
that were invented over or developed
over 20 years it is using low stretch
trees and that's not a coincidence it's
because of fundamentally the same basic
reason and that is that that
transformation matrix W which here is
used as a nons space basis and in uh in
in combinatorial preconditions is used
in in another way uh you want a npace
basis this W with a small Norm that's
how Bowman and hon came up with lower
trees and that's how ker is stud came up
with low stretch trees there are two key
ideas one which they express in one way
which is that they have a combinatorial
method to transform an ill condition the
hard small problem to a larger easy
problem and the way that I'm expressing
this which hopefully will be uh useful
in the future in generalization of this
is that this is a n space method you
take the problem you create a Nile space
of the relevant part of the Matrix and
that gives you the power to turn a hard
problem into a bigger easy problem the
other part that's very important and as
far as I know completely new in linear
algebra in algorithms in linear algebra
is an implicit way to represent the
iteration Vector rather than an explicit
representation to make iterations uh
cheap uh We've started doing uh
experiments with this it seems to have
large constants convergence seems very
slow so it's linear in the number of
edges but linear with the large constant
and the other thing that I want to
mention here which is also critical to
the question of whether we can turn this
into fantastic software is whether this
is the way they describe the algorithm
the way I currently understand the
algorithm it's inherently very very
sequential it's doing a linear number of
iterations the iterations themselves are
very cheap that's not good uh in terms
of parallelism so unless we can find uh
a paralyzed version and hopefully a
paralyzed version that's provably
parallel and provably effective rather
than a euristic uh this is not going to
turn into fantastic software there is a
lot of work to do here thank you very
much
one
question so ask a
question well the old methods are based
on well replacing a with u * U transpose
and in this case you were using inance
matrices well if if I already have the
factors in some of the not necessar
inance matrices so can you use them um
here I don't know I mean
in well it depend what kind of factors
you have the incidence factors are
really not something that's challenging
computationally it's just a different
way of representing the Matrix so you
can represent it as an array of matrixes
or as a a link list or so the U factors
are really exactly the same
representation so it's not doing
anything yet if you have factors that
are triangular factors or something
useful that that could be useful maybe
here but we don't know
so